uh I grew up in LA and he immigrated to
LA and I remember growing up with the
smog in Los Angeles and we were born
within three years of each other and you
probably read about it that the air in
Los Angeles was horrible the joke was I
don't touch I don't um I don't trust air
I can't touch but the smog was so bad
and you can see the pictures from Los
Angeles through the 70s they went to
unleaded fuel and and other things that
happened with power plants uh San onofre
went online which is an old nuclear
power plant in Southern California and
so I have a perspective in my own
lifetime that I have seen LA's air get
much better I don't look at this as oh
screw the grandkids I'm I'm out of here
in 40 years so you know I'm not worried
about it I don't look at it that way I
have perspective on Los Angeles which
was a horribly filthy City and now you
take a look